>> Bret: LOOKING LIVE ON
CAPITOL HILL WITH A VERY SPECIAL
GUEST TO BRING IN.
DANIEL KRAUTHAMMER, HE IS THE
SON OF LONG-TIME SYNDICATED
COLUMNIST AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER.
HE IS A FRIEND, AS HIS FATHER
WAS, AND COMPILED A BOOK OF HIS
LATE FATHER'S WORK, FINISHED AND
COMPLETED HIS LATE FATHER'S WORK
IN A BOOK CALLED "THE POINT OF
IT ALL: A LIFETIME OF GREAT LOVE
AND ENDEAVORS" WHICH COMES OUT
TOMORROW.
DANIEL, THANK YOU FOR DOING
THIS.
YOU CHOSE "SPECIAL REPORT" TO BE
THE FIRST INTERVIEW IS IMPORTANT
TO US.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME.
IT'S THE RIGHT PLACE TO DO IT.
ONLY PLACE TO DO IT.
>> Bret: HOW DID THIS COME TO
BE?
>> MY FATHER WAS WORKING ON A
SECOND COLLECTION, THE FOLLOW-UP
TO HIS 2013 BOOK, "THINGS THAT
MATTER."
HE WAS A LONG WAY INTO THE
PRICES WHAT IS HEALTH CRISIS
STRUCK A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO
NOW.
I GUESS 60 MONTHS AGO NOW.
HE WAS ABLE TO WORK ON IT DURING
HIS HOSPITALIZATION WHICH HELPED
HIM WITH, WE JERRY-RIGGED HIS
ROOM TO HELP USE THE COMPUTER TO
LOOK AT THIS AND CONTINUE
COMPILING THIS.
WHEN THE FINAL DIAGNOSIS CAME,
HE ENTRUSTED ME TO FINISH IT FOR
HIM.
SINCE HE PASSED IN JUNE, THAT'S
BEEN MY ABSOLUTE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
>> Bret: WHAT WAS IT THAT IS
SAID TO YOU ABOUT COMPILING THIS
BOOK?
I SHOULD POINT OUT THAT YOU DO
THE FORWARD AND ALSO A BEAUTIFUL
ENDING WHICH ACTUALLY IS THE
EULOGY YOU DELIVERED AT HIS
FUNERAL.
>> I HAD A SENSE OF WHERE HE
WANT TO GO, HE HAD ALREADY
CHOSEN MOST OF WHAT'S IN THE
BOOK NOW.
QUITE A BIT TO BE ADDED AND TO
BE ARRANGED AND MAKE SURE IT ALL
FIT TOGETHER AT THE CORE IDEAS
HE SPOKE THROUGH, WHICH WASN'T
TOO HARD BECAUSE HIS THINKING
AND HIS CLARITY WERE SO APPARENT
AND THEY CAME OUT FROM READING
THE BOOK FRONT TO BACK.
BUT I FINISHED THAT, PUT IT
TOGETHER.
AS YOU SAID, I WROTE AN
INTRODUCTION TO EXPLAIN HOW I
THOUGHT IT ALL CAME TOGETHER IN
CONJUNCTION WITH HIS POLITICS,
HIS PERSONALITY, HIS PHILOSOPHY,
HIS FUN PASSIONS.
THE LAST ENTRY IN THE BOOK IS
THE EULOGY I DELIVERED AT HIS
FUNERAL WHICH WAS A DIFFICULT
DECISION TO PUT THAT IN BECAUSE
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A VERY PERSONAL
AND CLOSE TO MY HEART.
BUT I WANTED THE WORLD TO KNOW
HOW WONDERFUL HE WAS AND HOW
EXTRAORDINARY HE WAS.
THAT WAS THE BEST WAY I KNEW
HOW.
>> I INTERVIEWED HIM MANY TIMES
FOR THE HOUR WE DID AND
SUBSEQUENT HOURS AND I TRIED TO
GET HIM TO TALK ABOUT YOU, YOUR
MOM ROBYN.
HE WAS ALWAYS A LITTLE HESITANT
THAT A LOT A LOT HESITANT, I
SHOULD SAY.
THIS HAS A LOT MORE PERSONAL
INFORMATION THAN I'VE EVER HEARD
CHARLES TALK ABOUT.
>> YEAH.
THAT WASN'T AN EASY DECISION
EITHER.
AS YOU SAY, HE WAS VERY PRIVATE,
ESPECIALLY ABOUT ME AND MY
MOTHER.
I THINK -- I LOVE HIM FOR THAT
AND HE WAS PROTECTING US.
NOT WANTING TO MAKE AS PART OF
HIS PROFESSION, HIS CAREER.
I'VE THOUGHT LONG AND DEEP ABOUT
HOW MUCH AND HOW PERSONAL TO GET
IN THIS BOOK, BUT AS I WROTE AN
INTRODUCTION, NOW THAT HE'S
GONE, IT'S DIFFERENT.
I THINK THERE IS A POWER TO HIS
VOICE, HIS FIRST-PERSON VOICE,
SPEAKING AS HIMSELF AND NOT HIS
POLITICAL ARGUMENTS THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE REACHED OUT TO ME
AND SPOKEN TO ME IN THE MONTHS
SINCE AND I REALIZED HOW MUCH HE
REALLY TOUCHED A LOT OF PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
I WANTED THE PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE THAT AND READ THAT.
I THINK HE WOULD APPROVED.
>> Bret: WE MISS HIS VOICE
EVERY NIGHT ON THIS PANEL.
I CAN TELL YOU HOW MANY EMAILS
AND TWEETS, "I WONDER WHAT
CHARLES THINKS ABOUT THIS.
I REALLY MISS HIS VOICE.
TODAY WITH THE REMEMBRANCE OF
THE 41ST PRESIDENT, I FOUND THIS
PICTURE WITH YOUR DAD, YOUR MOM
WITH PRESIDENT GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
AND A REFLECTION OF A COLUMN
LOOKING BACK AFTER HE LOSES IN
1992 IN WHICH HE SAYS, "BUSCH'S
WAS NOT A FAILED LEGACY BUT AN
UNCOMPLETED ONE.
HE WAS ASKED TO DO TWO THINGS.
CLOSE OUT THE COLD WAR AND CHECK
A TYRANTS EXCESSES IN -- AT THE
END OF FOUR YEARS, NOTHING FOR
HIM TO DO.
ALSO THE REASON HIS COUNTRY
TURNED HIM OUT OF OFFICE.
THE VOTERS JUDGMENT IS NOT TO BE
CONFUSED WITH HISTORIES DON'T
MAKE HISTORY'S.
IT MAY SERVE PARTISAN JOURNALISM
"WHAT'S AMAZING ABOUT CHARLES HE
COULD CUT THROUGH THE NOISE.
EVERYONE'S SAYING THIS, SAYING
THIS MOMENT, THIS PRESIDENCY WAS
LARGER THAN 38% HE RECEIVED IN
THAT ELECTION.
BUT HE SAID IT BACK IN 1992.
>> I HAD THE SAME FEELING.
I WAS LOOKING BACK AT HIS OLD
COLUMNS WHEN I HEARD THE NEWS
ABOUT FORMER
PRESIDENT GEORGE BUSH AND I WAS
STRUCK BY THIS TOO.
I LOOKED AT THE DATE LINE AND
WITH SO MANY PIECES OF HIS
WRITINGS THAT ARE IN THE HIS
BOOK AND OTHER PLACES, IT FEELS
LIKE IT COULD BE WRITTEN TODAY.
I REMEMBER YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER ON THE SHOW BUT THE
MENTION OF CHURCH HILL, AND
TRUMAN WHICH MY DAD ALSO
MENTIONED IN THIS ARTICLE, HE
HAD A VERY DEEP SENSE OF HISTORY
WHICH COMES THROUGH IN HIS
WRITINGS.
THE SENSE THAT SOME OF THE
GREATEST LEADERS, TO ACCOMPLISH
WHAT THEY NEED TO FOR HISTORY.
THEN THEIR TURN IS OVER.
IT WAS A VERY POETIC
APPRECIATION OF HISTORY.
>> Bret: THERE ARE AMAZING
THINGS IN THIS BOOK ABOUT
FOREIGN POLICY, DOMESTIC POLICY.
LONGER THAN IS COLUMNS CAN BE
EVEN.
SPEECHES.
NUGGETS THAT YOU WOULDN'T REALLY
SEE INTO HIS WRITE-UPS.
>> THERE ARE QUITE A FEW PIECES
IN THIS BOOK THAT WERE NOT
PUBLISHED ANYWHERE BEFORE.
ONE COMPLETELY NEW ORIGINAL
ESSAY ABOUT THE RISE OF
AUTHORITARIANISM AND POPULISM
THAT HE WROTE IN JULY OF 2017
THAT HAD NOT BEEN PUBLISHED.
SOME LONG RUMINATIONS ON THE BIG
IDEAS, WHAT IS AMERICA'S ROLE IN
THE WORLD, WHAT ARE THE
IDEOLOGICAL CHALLENGES TO
DEMOCRACY IN THE 21ST CENTURY?
ALONG WITH FUN STUFF LIKE
BASEBALL, CHESS, ALL THE REST OF
IT.
>> Martha: HE WAS SUCH AN
INTERESTING CHARACTER BUT I KNOW
MOST PEOPLE SAYING, LOOKING AT
THIS INTERVIEW WILL SAY, JUST
ASK, WHAT IS IT LIKE HAVING
CHARLES AS YOUR DAD?
>> WONDERFUL.
>> Bret: WE ASKED ABOUT HIS
LIMITATIONS.
OBVIOUSLY HE HAD LIMITATIONS.
BUT TO YOU, YOU DIDN'T SEE IT.
>> NO.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW GROWING
UP.
HE FACED DIFFICULTIES IN HIS
LIFE AND EVERYBODY FACES
DIFFICULTIES IN THEIR LIFE.
HE LIVED SUCH A FULL AND VIBRANT
LIFE LIKE HE WANTED AND HE MADE
AT THE LIFE THAT HE WANTED FOR
ME TOO.
I NEVER FELT WANTING FOR
ANYTHING.
IN FACT, AS I'VE GOTTEN OLDER,
I'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO LOOK BACK
AND REALIZE JUST HOW LUCKY I
WAS.
ESPECIALLY NOW.
I THINK ABOUT THAT ALL THE TIME.
>> Bret: WE WERE LUCKY TO HAVE
THEM FOR THE YEARS THAT WE DID
ESPECIALLY HERE ON
"SPECIAL REPORT."
THIS BOOK, I'M HONORED TO GIVE A
BLURB ON THE BACK.
IT SAYS THIS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE YOU MIGHT MEET
THROUGHOUT YOUR LIFE THAT YOU
JUST KNOW WILL LEAVE AN IMPACT
FOREVER.
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER WAS ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE.
HIS WORDS, HIS KNOWLEDGE, HIS
ELOQUENCE ARE THE ISSUES OF THE
DAY WERE UNSURPASSED.
HE COULD CUT THROUGH THE NOISE.
HE COULD GET TO THE POINT BETTER
THAN ANYBODY.
IT'S A REAL HONOR.